maria villarreal who's in beaumont texas
right now where people
are bracing for laura's impact maria
good morning to you what are you seeing
so far
hey good morning tony overnight we saw a
little bit of rain the wind is
definitely picking up a clear sign that
laura is creeping closer here in
jefferson county more than 250
thousand people are under mandatory
evacuation orders and still
some are choosing to ride out the storm
sheriff's office with the clock ticking
deputies delivered an urgent warning to
people living in flood pro neighborhoods
get out or be prepared to weather
hurricane laura from home
we may not be able to get to you marilyn
sachitano told us she's not leaving
she's lived in jefferson county for 27
years
and has stayed home through several
hurricanes this one's going to
it's scarier knowing that it's supposed
to be stronger and
you know still unpredictable just scary
to leave your stuff behind
but county sheriff zena stevens stressed
it will be critical
for people to heed mandatory evacuation
orders before it's too late
with a wind event you're going to lose
electricity the possibility of your roof
flying off your house it could be
catastrophic and many people have
followed those orders with some sitting
in bumper-to-bumper traffic
as they left galveston where local
businesses boarded up windows in
preparation for the worst
experts are predicting up to 15 feet of
storm surge in some areas
and water could push as far as 30 miles
inland
it's a threat complicated by the
coronavirus
now responsible for nearly 12 000 deaths
across the state
governor greg abbott issued this
reminder to evacuees
protect yourself as well as your
property
everyone must ensure that they protect
their lives also
from contracting coba 19.
laura's impending landfall also
affecting the regional oil refineries in
this area one report suggesting right
now that oil production in the gulf of
mexico has already been cut
by 84 percent as this hurricane
approaches gail all right maria thank
you very much